Phil encourage the radio show we're here
with Tony Elwood and Paul Barrett of the
film and cold storage and also synthetic
fur grip productions okay and let's talk
about your experience today I film
courage I mean you'd been on our show
previously but it was via Skype so Tony
you got to sit in and Paul unfortunately
you had to sit in the waiting room
because we're only allowed to have a
certain amount of people in studio how
was it to be here alive it was it was
actually very it was very good you know
because you guys are very interactive
it's interesting to see how you play off
each other you know it's nice being
around people when someone's acting your
questions you can tell if they're
sincere or not you know I I felt really
comfortable being here and it's a very
nice very polished setup it's just you
guys do a really good job i'm really
really proud of what you've what you're
doing here and just glad to be a part of
it and i enjoy sitting out here
listening Jourdan and commenting on what
you guys really are like puppet masters
in there it's amazing how you're able to
you know pull this stuff off of me I was
just floored you know I thought you'd
have like a team of like you know a
hundred people running around is you
know you guys sit down as like you know
Mission Control and bang you know just
all sort of comes together so it's
really nice job thank you very
professional thank you now a few minutes
ago we were talking about I think was
your first film and you mentioned how
you went ahead and tried to sell it
yourself by going around to different
mom-and-pop stores um and you had to
film on VHS tape can you tell us about
that yeah my first film I shot on a very
low budget film called killer and it was
it was back in I guess
484 yeah so baby no baby not a thank you
Bob 89 and you know the way to just
reach amount of work back then was there
there were a lot of video stores I mean
everywhere you could look it was at the
video stores kindly starbucks now and
and what I would do is I actually
duplicated the things myself I had the
boxes made myself I shrink wrap them
myself and I would throw him trunk of my
car and I would spend two weeks just
driving around from town to town within
I'm living in North Carolina so I went
you know from Virginia to West Virginia
to Atlanta in the south carolina area
and i hit every single mom and pop video
store and i've walked in and I would you
know usually you just get the person who
works there you know they have no clue
what you're talking about and leave a
cell sheet or something like that but
but the thing about it was a lot of
times you know the person who owned the
store was there you know and I would
just sit there and I would I had that
one-on-one contact with them and I could
almost not not forceful goodbye my film
but they saw the enthusiasm that I had
about my film and they needed content
and here i was making with content
decision maker you know whereas today
you don't have that opportunity there
there is no one on one unfortunately you
know with the way things are changing
now but but i did do i do really really
well and i'm hoping that someday some
kind of new technology will come along
to sort of replace that experience where
you know is the filmmakers are you know
they have the you know the one on one
experience with what you're able to you
know someone's watching your movie and
you can like you guys did with your with
your film Chet I thought that was
brilliant you know you could ask
questions you know you can see you had
the movie you know available right there
for people to to download and watch it
was just it was just a really nice
interactive fun for I mean I just think
that's the future now the two of you
worked together for several years is
that right
okay now how do you to delegate
responsibilities to one another because
I know in any team there's probably one
that's really good at social media
whereas the other ones more proficient
at getting things done behind the scenes
is that the case with the two of you
yeah I mean I think so Tony's tongues
the more I mean we're both creative but
Tony's more creative in the sense of the
actual physical production of it I
handle more of the money and making sure
that things are done on time and on you
know on budget and the Tony gets what he
needs but at the same time that we do it
within the money we have because you
know you can't have 20 k's and five
cranes and six cameras if you've only
got a hundred thousand dollars so that
sort of is more my department whereas
Tony hands and the actors and just all
the things that a director does but he
also handles the producing aspects
simply from a from a more creative end
of it who you know who the DP is going
to be who the talent is going to be and
then I just handle everything beyond
that and as far as the social media and
I mean you guys know I'm on Twitter all
the time I talk to you guys I talk to
everybody else Tony Tony has logged into
a Twitter account that hasn't been on it
if it once yeah those it ones and some
of that comes down to time I mean that's
that's sort of part of what I do with
the time I have whereas if tony has free
time he's either working on the next
script or creating something in the
computer or he's off doing his hobby
which is rockhounding so but Joe it's
like every second I had the you know
casino we all have day jobs at to a
certain degree and you know every free
second I have either creating content
for my next film or I'm creating
marketing materials for my current film
cold storage so you know I really have
no time to waste and Paul's really good
about taking that content
getting it out there on the internet
sharing it with people and getting
interest and you know and so is it was a
good relationship because I don't have
time for that and he doesn't have he
doesn't skills to do the difficulty of
the marketing pieces that I do I have
the artistic talent of a rock okay Ryder
but as far as are gonna happen
Oh